Hi, I'm brianna from Free Code Camp and today. We're going to be talking about Data speed
Data speed unlike Data size is usually measured in bits per second
Whereas size is measured in bytes
Big difference being bytes is eight times bigger than bits at the very smallest level once we start talking
Exponentially that makes a really big difference
How we talk about speed kind of depends on what we're talking about when we talk about the speed of like an audio download
We talk about kilobits per second
kilobits not kilobytes totally different number today
We're talking about an internet speed like the speed that your internet service provider gives you they usually measure that in megabits per second
so 1 million bits per second the network speed is something we talked about in gigabits per second so a
Billion bits per second biggest distinction here bits versus bytes Data speed is generally measured in bits
Data size is measured in bytes
Another thing we want to discuss
Just because they have an internet speed that
Says you get a certain amount of download that doesn't mean you're going to be able to download that many bytes
Per minute per second that's just not going to happen they're talking about bits
It's going to take you a little bit longer to do that since your data size is dealing with bytes